[Musique]
on compte à paris huit cent cinquante
mille véhicules deux fois plus qu'en
1939 et de nouveaux véhicules
cent quarante mille par an s'élance sur
la chaussée si l'on peut dire si
personne ne s'arrêtait les rues seraient
encore assez large
hélas les incitations à leur convenance
indifférent au temps qui passe et les
autres en quête d'une place sont
condamnés au mouvement perpétuel
on sait que le stationnement en double
file gêne tout le monde et qu'il creuse
entre les êtres
un fossé d'incompréhension quant à cette
dame venue d'ailleurs
elle serait bien infliger de savoir
qu'elle provoque en toute innocence
un encombrement qui va ralentir le
trafic sur un long parcours
avez vous vraiment besoin de votre
voiture madame le médecin lui ne peut se
passer de la sienne
n'utilisez pas votre voiture sans
nécessité et ne stationnez pas trop
longtemps
c'est le conseil du préfet de police
[Musique]